within our tissues we have a specialized
group of cells called stem cells that
are able to expand their own pool but
also give rise to all the specialized
cells within our tissue and our tissue
needed to maintain this ability of
producing new specialized cells which is
called
regeneration so while we know the stem
cells and the environment in which the
cells reside is critical to this
regeneration process we still lack
knowledge of how stem cells undertake
the sequential steps that will lead to
the tissue to regenerate we've only had
snapshots of these very dynamic
processes and now using the two-photon
microscope and special transgenic mice
were able to visualize how stem cells
and their progeny and other cell types
behave during the regeneration process
at the photo microscope is a microscope
that uses near-infrared light in order
to visualize live tissues because it has
the ability to penetrate deeper into the
tissue and cause less damage to the
tissue to orient you a little bit these
are hair follicles these are structures
that say several micrometers which would
below the surface of the skin here you
see the hair shaft extending outside on
the surface of the skin and this is the
structure the rooted inside the terminus
the arrows are pointing to division cell
divisions that are taking place in real
time first of all what we showed with
this study is the technological advance
that it's possible to visualize how
tissue regeneration takes place in a
normal physiological environment in a
live animal furthermore we found that
divisions that take place in the hair
follicle during regeneration are in fact
regulated which means certain cells are
dividing in certain places and in
certain orientations also we found that
cells within the hair follicle have the
ability to reorganize
and move directionally to support the
organized growth of the hair follicle
and last we showed that we are able to
manipulate the hair follicle and the
tissue in order to remove specific cells
and visualize what the impact of that
removal is to the ability of the tissue
to regenerate and repair itself so the
reason why we think this work is very
exciting is because it provides for the
first time the ability to understand
stem cell behavior in real time don't
invest in a model system such as the
mouse what we think is gonna come out of
this work and those are already lines of
Investigation that we are pursuing is
their understanding of the signaling
mechanism that governs the behaviors
that we have been able to characterize
and so while we know that there are
important - regenerative signals such as
winds or also be in peace the regulate
tissue regeneration in the skin as well
as in other organs we still fail to
understand which cells and which
behaviors are regulated by these signals
and so now using genetic approaches
combined with our live imaging we can
understand by altering this signaling
pathway which souther which behaviors
wint and BMP are controlling
you